[Applause]
in this part of Texas with natural
disasters in the news the country is
being treated to a real-time debate over
the sins of so-called price gouge your
price gouging in our state I'm gonna go
after you and I will shame you on
national TV
defenders of gouging including many
libertarians stress that price hikes
force customers to prioritize their
purchases while incentivizing suppliers
to bring necessities to market so if
jugs of water are selling at $10 a
gallon businesses have a motivation to
truck them in one of the advantages of
letting prices rise is it forces people
to make the tough decisions and at that
price no one's gonna use that water to
wash their cars critics however say that
it's immoral to use the price mechanism
to meet her out essentials in a crisis
you know we're gonna now see people
coming in from other states trying to
sell generators for $1,000 to take care
of you know to hurt people in need it's
disgusting if anybody price gouges this
is not the time to take advantage of her
neighbors if both sides ignore a more
important reality local and national
businesses routinely give away goods and
services much more efficiently than
public sector responders or charities
can manage we saw what was happened
Florida we thought what could we do to
help our neighbors in Florida as well in
the wake of Hurricane Harvey slamming
Texas business has pledged over 72
million dollars in aid with over three
dozen giving more than 1 million dollars
apiece
Airbnb used its Home Sharing Network to
set up places for people to stay and the
crowdsource mapping app Waze helped a
displaced find shelters Walmart
the left's favorite corporate boogeyman
pledged more than 20 million dollars in
brought water and food to the needy
during Hurricane Katrina the world's
largest retailer truck didn't relief
long after FEMA convoy stopped running
we will also match those donations two
to one up to 10 million dollars bringing
the whole total to 30 million
private-sector aid gets less press than
empty shelves and gouging accusations
but it also makes good business sense in
some cases price hikes during a crisis
are appropriate but most retailers know
they're better off showing that they
care about their customers and aren't
out to take advantage of a bad situation
successful businesses safeguard their
reputations in the wealth of nations
Adam Smith wrote that he had never known
much good done by people motivated by
charitable aims but providing aid in
disasters is every bit as much of a part
of the free market as more obvious forms
of profit shake it if critics and
defenders of gouging are really
interested in creating a better society
they do well to help make this part of
the invisible hand visible to all
[Music]
[Music]